Been.
Hillary was the stereotypical country bumpkin hailing from rural New Zealand.
The shy,
gangly beekeeper steps out of the shadows to take on one of the greatest
physical challenges of them all.
Climbing the world's highest mountain through guts,
script,
and determination.
He managed to,
as he famously says,
knock the bast it off.
From there,
he used his newfound fame as a platform to improve the lives of the Nepalese
people who had developed an affinity for leaving behind the legacy of it endures
beyond the record books.
In today's buying graphics,
we look at the life and the accomplishments of the first demands.
Who ever climbed Mount Everest,
Sir Edmund Hillary.
It means first of all,
we're going to read was born on July the 20th 1919 in Aucklands and New
Zealand's shortly after the birth of his father,
Percival or Augustus was allocated a land grants in recognition of his service
during the first world war as a results,
the family,
which included three year olds in June,
moved itself to the finding sediments of two cow or younger.
Brother.
Rex soon came along June.
Later described the three boys as follows,
as had the brains,
racks have the looks,
and I was the girl according to ads own recollections.
It was his mother who held the family together.
She managed the money that's made sure that the kids were okay.
This was no easy task.
Hillary children has an adventurous streak that saw them pushing everything to
the limits.
One seven racks swap to bicycles with edge riding on the one that was too small
for him.
Rex,
however,
founded hard to control the larger bike still living.
The tag would be chasing him.
He went as fast as he could turning your corner.
He collided with a car bouncing off the bonus and then bouncing off the road.
The driver was terrified that he had killed racks,
but ed was merely terrified of the beating he knew his father would give him
when he saw the state of the bike.
Although Percy was a pacifist,
he was prone to fits of rage.
These bursts of rage.
Think we usually directed at his oldest son,
even though he feared the beatings,
the southern edge was determined to never give his father the satisfaction of
admitting that he had done anything wrong despite the competitive bond with his
brother.
Ed's other,
yes,
they were filled with loneliness throughout this primary years.
He didn't make any friends while other kids were out playing.
He fills his time with extra tuition,
which allows him to enter high school two years ahead of his peers.
This only made his social situation worst,
though he was now shorter and the younger than all the other kids high school
men's,
that he had to take the train to the prestigious Auckland Grammar school and rub
shoulders with the children of the wealthy.
This intensified his lack of self confidence and social awkwardness.
Even further in his later years often recounts an incidents that occurred during
his first week.
You could Auckland's grammar that had a deep impact on him.
He turns up for his first gym class along with his classmates.
The teacher surveyed his new students and then fixing his gaze on Ed said,
what have they sent me?
He then went zones,
the catalog,
a long list of what he saw was wrong with that.
Finally,
he told the humiliated boy to go against the wall with the other misfits.
Ed Recalls that this incident is marked the beginning of a sense of inferiority
about his looks,
which would remain with him for the rest of his life.
Ed founds the companionship that he lacks with other humans in books.
After waiting through the typical teenage and literary attractions of the days
such as Edgar Rice Burroughs and h a Haggis,
he discovered books on mounds and narrowing.
They fascinated him and he devoured everything on the subject that he could get
his hands on personally around the local newspaper in the town and had a
sideline business as a beekeeper in 1935 and in last year at Oakland Grammar,
the family moved to the inner Oakland suburb of rem or era.
Beekeeping now became the family's main source of income.
The changements that adds no longer had to spend hours on the train every single
day
from college,
Edwin's homes of the University of Auckland where he studied mathematics and
science.
He also joins the university tramping club with his long stride and is abundance
stamina.
He seemed became a star Bush Walker.
He also took lessons in boxing and Jujitsu that head to head combat.
It wasn't his style in 1938 as who had been struggling academically drops out of
the university and joined his father in the beekeeping business.
His Stamina,
endurance,
and physical strength were ideally suited for the job.
It was hot,
physically demanding work,
and in the summer he would carry out his duties wearing only shorts or a hat and
a veil every day it would have to India up to 300 bee stings.
Not long after ed began working on the beef farm,
his parents converted to a new age,
religious movements called radiant living.
The group had beliefs that we're not far removed from those of Christian
scientists at and his brother,
rex,
they soon became converts to when war broke out in 1939 it appears inevitable
that both Hillary boys would be drafted into the New Zealand armed services,
but proceed.
The pacifist was determined to prevent this from happening.
He managed to get himself off the hook by relying on a provision that allowed
exemptions for reserved occupations including beekeeping.
However,
that person,
he did all of this without telling Ed who was not happy to hear about his
father's meddling personally soon discovered there's only one exemption per
family was allowed as exemption men,
so the corrects would have to go to war.
It just so happens though that racks,
unlike Ed,
was a conscientious objector ad would have been happy to sign up or there's
wrecks wasn't.
He followed his conscious and spent the next four years in a detention camp for
three years and fumes silently that his father had prevented him from fulfilling
what he saw as his patriotic duty.
Finally,
in 1944 he joins the Royal New Zealand Air Force.
It was during his training as a flight navigator in New Zealand,
South Islands that had encountered towering mountains.
He managed to get in a few solo climbs.
Then he came across the 2,884 meters,
snu camps and mounts,
Tapper Werner crew.
He became determined to make an a sense and arranged for a three day leave.
He arranged do plan the mountain with a partner,
but the man pulled out at the last minute and decided to go at alone with a
friend taking him part of the way on his motorbike.
He then walked eight kilometers to a farm where he stayed overnight.
The next day he walked another 24 kilometers.
Overnight it there's another farm and then set off the mountain.
He reached the top without any trouble anti returned safely.
The next day he walked another 32 kilometers before receiving a left and it was
delighted with this first experience.
He had knocked off his first mountain and it felt
returning to his war service had found himself a stations to the Pacific
islands.
Years later,
he would recall coming across this small Fijian boy who came up and begged for a
piece of bread experiences like this form the catalyst for his great
humanitarian work that he would pursue later in life ads.
He never came there combat though he did contract malaria.
His war also nearly ended in disaster when a full petrol tank in his plane fell
and burst into flames.
The plane came down into the ocean before ads who was not wearing a shirt could
jump Claire of the Blazer and craft a wave,
knocked him off his feet and he fell into the flames.
He then managed to roll off the plane and into the sea.
Ed suffered secondary bands and the pain was made worse by going having to swim
450 meters and then walk 800 meters under the blazing sun before he reached
help,
he was taken to a hospital in Guadalcanal where he was shot full of morphine and
antibiotics.
He was told that he would be in bed for months before he could achieve a full
recovery.
However,
within two weeks he was up and walking about.
He became so restless and so board that he begged his doctors to allow him to
recover at home in Oakland.
They finally relented and he was discharged from the air force and sent home.
When I got home.
He didn't intend to buy rounds but rather gets work,
but when he discovered that his father had taken on other workers and to no
opening for him on the beef farm,
he moved to the South Islands in search of new opportunities.
He joins the New Zealand Alpine club and over the next couple of years he learns
their climate is craft as he took on many of the mountain there,
speaks of the South Island and its claims with others but always wanted to be
the first to the top.
In 1949 oldest sister June got married personally had enjoyed and especially
good honey season and he paid for ed to travel with his parents to Europe edge.
Took every opportunity to take on European peaks including the Aiga Molly
was in Europe.
I had received a letter from a former climbing partner by the name of George
Lowe informing him that plans were underway.
Of a New Zealand party.
If you undertake a track of the Himalayas,
they intended to explore the possibility of tackling the world's highest peak
Mount Everest,
something that had never been done successfully before low.
He wants you to know whether Hillary was interested.
The answer as well as you might imagine,
it was an unequivocal yes and mountaineering terms.
There was no greater challenge than a successful,
a sense of Mount Everest,
which Tau is 8,848 meters from the ground.
Many climbers had died trying to get their most famous famously the British
climber,
George Mallory and 1924 but turning point in the history of attempts on Everest
occurred in 1950 when the Nepalese government agreed to allow parties to attempt
the mountain from Nepal on the southern side.
Previous expeditions at attacks from Tibet on the northern side of the mountain,
the Nepalese government decided to let a different country every year half ago.
It just so happens that in addition to the New Zealand group,
a party of British climbers,
we're also planning and assault on Everest.
The British group sent a letter to the New Zealand,
does suggesting that they join up the invitation.
However,
it was only for two clients.
The question was now,
well you go after some heated discussion.
It was decided that edge,
the acknowledged superior Kleiner and I'll read a third would be the token New
Zealanders on the British expedition rather than a concerted effort to reach the
summit.
This expedition was more of an exploratory probe while climbing with shifts in
the expedition leader and every came across a vast hidden valley that appeared
to provide a previously unknown route to the top.
The group split up and agreed to return the next year.
The following year in 1952 however,
was assigned to a Swiss expedition.
Attempts to climb Everest,
the British within New Zealand contingents that have to wait until 1953
burning.
The 1953 assaults began in a small office in London.
It was led by Eric Shipton who believed that the journey should be made by a
small team with basic supplies but shipped and has only just begun choosing his
team when there was a sudden change of plan.
Previous attempts to climb Everest by small teams had failed and it was decided
that this time they would use a big team with the latest equipment and plenty of
suppliers and new leader.
John Harms was appointed in March of 1953 the expedition team began to arrive in
Katmandu.
The team got ready to make their way east to the Himalayas and Mount Everest.
Hillary was one of 14 climbers and more than 30 Nepalese shoppers who made up
the team.
Nearly 400 people set off from Katmandu on March the 10th more than 350 of them
were locals who are hired to carry supplies to the site for the first camp for
17 days.
They walked through the Nepalese countryside until they arrived base camp.
Then they stayed for three weeks planning for clients to come.
They practiced with their climbing gear on local cliffs and tried to get used to
the thin air if the high mountains in early April base camp was moved from near
Tengboche monastery to a second main base.
The lake camp hire up by a lake on a glacier.
The first big challenge for the leaders came on April the 13th for men,
including Hillary,
were selected by Hans to explore a region known as the Khumbu icefall.
This was an area of how sized blocks of ice that cracked and creaked.
The claim has had to find a safe route for the Nepalese Sherpas who were to
follow bringing suppliers a number of camps that were set up through the icefall
that leads climbers press through the Khumbu icefall and set up advanced base
camp above it.
But I now Hillary had impressed all with his boundless energy and exceptional
strength.
Early on in the morning of April,
the 26 ads have teamed up with Sherpa Tenzing Norgay for the first time.
That task was to reach an advanced camp.
It was set up during the previous year's Swiss expedition ropes.
Together.
The two men waded through deep,
slushy snow that had a shortened with the sun's rays despite being hot and
thirsty.
The Path worked well together.
Arriving at the camp,
they founds an unexpected treat.
The Swiss had left behind some supplies,
which included delicious gs all the way back to base camp.
Hilary boasted to Norgay that he could make it back within an hour all when's
well until he decided to leap across a crevasse.
He reached the other side,
but the edge of the crevasse broke off.
Suddenly he was slipping downwards and his fate was in the hands of his partner.
Fortunately,
Norgay was a brilliant climber.
He quickly grabbed a hold of the pole and he used all of his skill,
strength and experience to help Hillary climb up to the side of the crevasse
resenting to base camp.
The bonds between the two men had been strengthened by Hilary's narrow escape
and then reread to his parents that he had Norgay had become the Tigers of the
campaign.
On that day.
They had shown strength,
courage,
and fearlessness,
and they hoped that that would take them to the top of Everest.
By late May,
delete climbers had scaled the lots they face to the south called the flat area.
That is one of the nastiest places on Everest.
Yet they start out with the seventh camp.
This was where they would make their final push to the summit to other climbers
were selected to make first push,
but they only made it to the lower south summit
on the morning of May,
the 28th five more climbers set off from the south Cole,
three lead climbers without a steps for the two men who had been picked to go
all the way to the top.
Hillary and Tenzing by nightfall.
They help us a turns back and now it was up to the two of them.
Hillary and Tenzing pitched their tents below Everest south summit on an Aleve
and Ice Ledge at 6:30 AM on May the 29th they began their final journey to the
summit while climbing a steep slope.
The surface no shifted carrying Hillary with us.
Then with their oxygen running low,
the two men came to a rock face.
It was too slippery to try and climb hard rock in the crampons fitted to their
boots.
They had to find another way.
Hilary sorta corners attached to a rock and it started to come away leaving your
crack,
stretching upwards between the rock and the ice.
He crawled into the crack and grasping the rock in front of him.
He pulled himself further in.
Drowning is crampons into the ice.
He pulled himself through the crack at the top of the cornice and signaled to
Norgay to follow.
They now continued along the Ridge hoping the summit would come into view just
as Hillary doubt as if they could go on.
He looked up and sort of sneaky peek that dropped away on all sides.
Hillary himself later recalled a few more whacks of the ice ax,
a few more weary steps and we were on the summit.
It was now time to celebrate,
to take photographs and appreciates and the best view in the wells.
Then use the terrorist did finally been conquered.
Reach the outside world on June.
The second Ed was lionized as the beekeeper from rural New Zealand who had done
the impossible from Nepal.
He flew to London where he was appointed a nice commander of the British Empire
by the newly crowned Queen Elizabeth the second he resides in New Zealand as a
conquering hero with thousands flooding the streets to get a glimpse of him for
the awkward and shy young man that he was this unexpected adulation.
It was hard to get used to a few months after conquering Everest,
Hillary made under the conquest he won over and married Louise,
Mary Rose.
This time,
however he needed help,
he was so shy that he had to rely on his mother in law to propose on his behalf.
This union later produce three children,
Peter,
Sarah,
and Belinda.
Peter would become a client and just like his father reaching the summit of
Everest himself in 1990 both Hillary and Tenzing continued climbing with
Hillary,
tackling 10 more Himalayan peaks over the next decade.
On January the fourth 1958 he led an expedition to Antarctica following the
route of Robert Falcon Scott.
In 1912 the New Zealanders became the first to make the track in motorized
vehicles with ad writing attractor.
Henrie later became an unofficial ambassador for New Zealand's in the 1970s he
commentated on the several and you went talk ticks sightseeing flights.
On November the 28th 1979 he was booked to work on flight nine oh one but had to
renege due to other work commitments.
That flight crashed into a mountain in Antarctica with everyone on board being
killed.
As the years went by,
Hillary returned increasingly to Nepal.
Then he became absorbed in programs of fundraising and building work for shatter
communities.
In 1960 he established the Himalayan trust,
which was responsible for the building of many schools and hospitals throughout
a remote Himalayan areas.
Hillary received terrible news though.
In 1975 tragedy struck with his wife and daughter Belinda being killed in a
plane crash while flying to join him in the Pool Devastated Hillary and must
himself and his building work.
However,
this was becoming increasingly difficult as he was getting more and more
altitude sick.
Henry's health deteriorated in the late 1990s on January the 11th 2008 his heart
finally gave out.
He died at the Auckland City hospital from cardiac arrest.
His country,
they went into mourning at a state funeral,
was held on January the 20 seconds,
two months later,
a Thanksgiving service was held in his honor at some George's chapel in Windsor
Castle standing guard outside the chapel with Gurkha soldiers from Nepal showing
that respect for a man who had given so much to improve the lot of that people.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice,
and as always,
thank you for watching.